[Música]
la crisis política y la represión en
nicaragua han llevado a numerosas ong
exiliarse en costa rica desde 2018 el
gobierno de daniel ortega le ha retirado
la personería jurídica a más de 1000
organizaciones sin fines de lucro
la violencia en haití ha forzado a
cientos de menores de edad a escapar de
cité soleil uno de los distritos más
pobres de puerto príncipe la capital
ahora los menores se refugian en un
instituto de la ciudad
eeuu siguen enfrentando temperaturas de
calor extremas el estado de texas espera
temperaturas entre los 40 y los 43
grados centígrados
expertos insisten en que estas
prolongadas olas de calor en el
hemisferio norte se deben al cambio
climático
bienvenidos a esta misión con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
centroamérica en medio de una crisis
sociopolítica y de derechos humanos que
persiste desde 2018 en nicaragua las
autoridades han eliminado la personería
jurídica de más de 1000 organizaciones
sin fines de lucro varias han trasladado
sus labores al vecino costa rica- cindy
regidor corresponsal de france 24 nos
cuenta las historias de tres de ellas
la hermana paola salió expulsada por el
gobierno nicaragüense junto a sus 17
compañeras de la asociación misioneras
de la caridad ahora desde costa rica
hacen su labor social pero lamenta no
poder seguir ayudando a los más
desprotegidos en nicaragua dolor con
pena pero sabiendo pues que desde la fe
ve viendo que es la voluntad de dios no
entendemos por qué pero la voluntad de
dios siempre está ahí verdad las
autoridades en nicaragua anularon a más
de mil ongs de toda índole inclusive
universidades como la paulo freire su
rector considera que es una represalia
por su respaldo a universitarios que
protagonizaron masivas protestas contra
el gobierno hace cuatro años desde san
jose imparte clases a nicaragüenses
refugiados tememos
a contribuir
a que la generación de jóvenes que fue
pulsada el país se eduque el cierre de
organizaciones empezó en 2018 elvira
cuadra trabajaba en ese entonces para
dos centros de investigación social y
académica que fueron obligados a cerrar
sus puertas decidió fundar uno nuevo en
costa rica la investigadora considera
que la abolición de la sociedad civil es
un objetivo del presidente daniel ortega
mientras exista sociedad civil mientras
existan organizaciones sociales en
nicaragua
eso constituye un
factor
que
contravienen su proyecto de estado
policial y de continuidad en el poder la
asamblea nicaragüense controlada por el
oficialismo justifica que las
organizaciones han incumplido las leyes
naciones unidas- rechaza el actuar del
gobierno de ortega y ha dicho que sin
espacio cívico no hay democracia
en haití cientos de menores de edad
escaparon de la violencia con la que
deben convivir en cité soleil uno de los
distritos más pobres y peligrosos de
puerto príncipe la capital del país los
menores ahora están refugiados en la
ciudad de un instituto de la ciudad
según la onu la violencia entre bandas
delincuenciales en haití se ha cobrado
la vida más de 900 personas en lo que va
de 2022 un prestigioso instituto
transformado en un hogar cientos de
niños y adolescentes haitianos se
refugian en la institución san luís
gonzaga
para escapar de la violencia de las
bandas de cité soleil uno de los
municipios más pobres y peligrosos de
latinoamérica
sólo este mes murieron más de 400
personas a manos de las pandillas en
este lugar
tu salud
sí no
en cité soleil todo el mundo es víctima
niños recién nacidos mujeres embarazadas
varias personas han muerto yo soy una
víctima porque he perdido a una persona
cercana una amiga le dispararon cuando
iba a visitar a su padre que celebraba
su cumpleaños
los niños comenzaron a llegar a la
escuela hace una semana reciben
alimentos se divierten y duermen en las
aulas de este establecimiento llegar
hasta aquí fue todo una hazaña se
pusieron uniformes escolares
convenciendo a los líderes de las bandas
de que iban a la escuela logrando
escapar de la guerra territorial
el lugar donde vivimos está controlado
por gpp una banda armada y la otra se
llama g9 por eso somos víctimas de la
violencia y hay muchas cosas que no
podemos decir para evitar la violencia
la afinación
la onu ha llamado a impedir el
suministro de armas a las bandas
criminales de haití sin embargo
organizaciones como la red nacional de
defensa de los derechos humanos han
denunciado que el gobierno es parte del
conflicto y que promueve que la policía
haitiana se mantenga al margen de los
enfrentamientos
un tribunal de washington declaró steve
banon ex asesor del ex presidente de
donald trump culpable de desacato al
congreso por su negativa a comparecer
ante el comité que investiga el asalto
al capitolio ocurrido el 6 de enero de
2021 también por negarse a entregar
documentos a las autoridades judiciales
se espera que el anuncio de la condena
tome entre 60 y 90 días aproximadamente
banon podría enfrentar una pena de entre
30 días y un año de prisión así como una
multa de hasta 100 mil dólares
estadounidenses por cada cargo
quiero empezar agradeciendo al jurado
respetamos su decisión de hoy realmente
quiero agradecer a esos ciudadanos
trabajadores que tuvieron que tomarse
una semana entera para pasar por esto
así que gracias respetamos su decisión
puede que hayamos perdido una batalla
aquí hoy pero no vamos a perder esta
guerra
en eeuu el calor extremo pone en alerta
a las autoridades en el estado de texas
se esperan temperaturas entre los 40 y
43 grados celsius este aumento en los
termómetros del hemisferio norte se debe
en parte al calentamiento climático
según los científicos
un calor sofocante atraviesa arizona y
marca la rutina de sus habitantes me
detengo periódicamente a lo largo del
día para asegurarme de que estoy
conservando la energía y manteniendo mi
temperatura moderada solo tienes que
estar atento a los signos de
deshidratación y sobrecalentamiento iré
en texas los lugareños salen a
refrescarse
oh hombre se siente agradable y
relajante para entrar en el agua fresca
este calor es una locura he visto a
mucha gente desmayarse con este calor
esta voz decir pero una práctica que
parece tan efectiva como natural podría
ser nociva para la salud ellos creen que
los enfríe lo que la gente no se da
cuenta es que realmente se suda incluso
en la piscina así que si la percepción
es que estás más fresco pero la realidad
es que probablemente no les des la
oficina del servicio meteorológico
nacional de houston advirtió sobre
temperaturas máximas de entre 40 y 43
grados celsius e instan a permanecer en
el interior evitar actividades
extenuantes y mantenerse hidratado
el potencial de calor extremo continuará
esencialmente hasta principios de
septiembre porque las cosas tienden a
seguir secándose y el golfo de méjico
tiende a seguir calentándose
a principios de esta semana varios
lugares del sur registraron temperaturas
diarias récord como wichita falls en
texas donde el martes se registró una
máxima de 46 grados las olas de calor en
el hemisferio occidental que han
afectado también a europa causando
devastadores incendios pueden ser
avivadas por el cambio climático según
los expertos
en la ciudad de san diego en california
se realiza el evento conocido como
cómico que ha vuelto tras una pausa de
dos años a causa de la pandemia los
detalles en el siguiente informe
desde personajes que puedes reconocer
hasta algunos que tal vez no los fans
del play están más animados que nunca
para la primera cómic con a gran escala
en tres años no hay nada como esto en el
mundo así que me siento como un niño en
una tienda de caramelos era una especie
de cosa indefinida estaba pensando que
nunca íbamos a tener con mí con de nuevo
así que estoy realmente emocionada de
estar aquí las dos últimas ediciones del
evento se celebraron en línea debido al
cob y 19 y hubo una asistencia limitada
en un evento reducido en san diego el
pasado noviembre pero se espera que la
asistencia de este año iguale los
niveles anteriores al surgimiento de la
pandemia con más de 130.000 aficionados
todos están obligados a mostrar una
prueba de vacunación contra el cubrir
una prueba negativa y a llevar tapabocas
además de cualquier otra máscara que
puedan tener me encanta es agradable
estar de vuelta era una tradición que
tenía y luego llevé a mi mujer en
nuestra primera cita a la comic-con así
que es algo muy especial para nosotros y
en cuanto mi hijo tenga la edad
suficiente lo llevaré también los
estudios de entretenimiento están
presentando una amplia gama de nuevos
contenidos pero los titulares de la
semana van a estar dominados por enormes
cerillas de fantasía que llegarán a las
pantallas de televisión próximamente el
señor de los anillos' los anillos del
poder de amazon prime y un nuevo
spin-off de juego de tronos de hb o
llamado la casa del dragón
y cerramos en eeuu la peruana kimberly
garcía se consagró en este mundial de
atletismo en eugene en el estado de
oregón como una de las mejores
marchistas del planeta a sus 28 años
garcía se proclamó campeona en los 35
kilómetros marcha es un oro que se suma
al que ya había conquistado hace justo
una semana en la prueba de los 20
kilómetros se trata de las primeras
medallas para perú en la historia de
este certamen
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]